as we head into Peak wedding season AKA
summertime today's money watch looks at
some Financial topics every couple
should talk about before they say I do
not an easy conversation but the good
news is many couples are in fact having
that difficult conversation a survey
from the wedding planning website the
knot finds that 86 percent of millennial
couples anyway are talking about
finances before engagement in fact and
it goes up to 90 percent for Gen Z
couples CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger uh joins us now uh and Joe
I think the really hard part is actually
beginning the conversation so what tips
do you have for people getting started
well first of all this often as we see
with the younger folks it takes place
when you're starting to cohabitate and
so we have real conversations about it I
want to remind everyone why it's so
important number one if something bad
happens to your spouse you kind of want
to know like are we on the same page and
we have to get some things taken care of
but number two if you're not talking
about your money there can be a weird
power Dynamic that develops among
couples so we want people to have
conversations about their financial
goals hey what do you think is important
in our lives number two we're going to
share information what does that mean
what kind of debt are you bringing into
this marriage what are our credit
ratings really important because if
you're going to go get a mortgage this
is important how much are we earning
what do you what's your savings habit
what about your investing what about
your risk tolerance these are so
important and of course first I wouldn't
be me if I don't end a segment like this
or the first question without saying
Wills durable powers of attorneys and
health care proxies please please please
we got to get that can you stand on
joint banking accounts I've always
thought when I first got married I
thought everything was 50 50. I once won
an office pool of 24 I came home and
gave him 12.50 I'm not kidding because I
thought you know we're married and we
should share everything now I feel
you have yours I have mine and we have
something joined together where do you
stand on joint banking accounts I don't
have a huge feeling on it I feel like
you must have the conversation and I
think is there a right or wrong no there
is no right or wrong and what's
interesting about it is I think more
people are ascribing to your latter
development in that on this where
because you're getting married later you
already have an account so I think it
does make sense for those couples but
I've heard from a lot of people where
there's a non-working spouse at home
that's right it feels weird about like
oh are you going to give me an allowance
like that feels strange whatever it is
talk about it make sure everyone's on
the same page it's an interesting point
because you said something interesting
there that uh we got married later in
life and so we have entire careers and
lives and so when we came into it
there's no there's transparency here
this is what I make this is what's in
the account
um but we've never come to the decision
to say well let's just combine
everything and I think it might be messy
right it can be and I also think that
when we're talking about this topic we
also have to acknowledge that there's a
lot of wage disparity when a couple
comes together and that can make it
Katie was not
but they say in a relationship he who
has the money has the power do you think
that's true
um not necessarily because I think that
whoever has I I think that what really
it has to happen is having a
conversations okay we come to this later
in life or we're starting out who's
managing the bill paying who's going to
do that now the reason why I think one
person usually is responsible for that
is that one person has a system that's
pretty seamless the other person often
doesn't but whatever your system is that
you're choosing talk about it I have had
couples who said you know oh you know so
and so my cous my husband had an
accident I don't even know how to pay
the utility bill so let's make sure
everyone shares passwords knows where
the accounts are so how do you start
this tough conversation because it's
still so hard for many people I think
when you're talking about and uh you're
let's bring Katie and let's do a little
couple's therapy right now I remember I
distinctly remember we were walking down
the street and we did we just set our
numbers uh yeah that's what you got to
do I think they do have very low and I
just gone you know when you get you want
to talk here's the reason we can end on
this the reason you should talk about
this is because couples fight over money
if you don't exactly and for those
people who are having real problems you
may want to bring in a third party a
financial advisor to help you walk
through this process develop your game
plan together the advice is always Jill
sessions are great to have you thank you